From banking ATMs to retail kiosk
services to manufacturing assembly lines,
intelligent devices are an integral
tool that we use to conduct business.
To handle the scale of these deployments and
exploit their compute capacity, edge computing
brings enterprise applications closer to where
the data is created and actions need to be
taken. It also allows enterprises to leverage
AI and analyze their data in near-real time.
While edge computing creates unique
opportunities, it also presentschallenges.
By breaking down the neat physical
boundaries of cloud data centers,
edge computing requires companies to consider
security, management, and compliance for tens
or even tens of thousands of offsite cameras,
sensors, and AI-ready factory controllers.
The pervasiveness of these edge devices
can rapidly lead to a management problem
that can't be handled without automation.
Without autonomous management of these
edge devices, the diversity of your
device inventory can also make traditional
software delivery costly and error prone.
It's also important to remember
that these devices change often.
For example, they are reconfigured in the
field with more memory, storage, or connected
to different sensors. They are re-purposed to
different tasks. They are moved or change owners.
A final point to consider: without
autonomous management of the edge devices,
the lack of continuous connectivity
can lead to security exposures,
outages, or missed opportunities to provide
specialized offers to your customers. So,
your edge device management strategy must consider
devices that are available online or offline.
Today I'll explain how IBM Edge
Application Manager can automate
the deployment and maintenance
of your edge device inventory.
You'll see how with autonomous management,
a single administrator can manage the scale,
variability, and rate of change of application
environments across tens of
thousands of endpoints.
IBM Edge Application Manager allows you
to dramatically reduce the administrator’s
burden by defining deployment intent instead of
coding and maintaining endless install scripts.
It also manages your endpoints in one place
with the RedHat OpenShift platform that
runs on the cloud of your choice.
Okay - Imagine that you work for
a fictitious company, "World-of-Widgets".
You're about to roll out a new assembly line
across your factories that can apply customized
painting for the widgets that you're producing.
To ensure the quality of custom painting,
a set of programmable cameras are
installed on every assembly machine.
However, this creates a
challenge for your IT department:
how do you manage all those devices and make sure
that they quickly adapt to new painting patterns?
World-of-Widgets has decided to
use IBM Edge Application Manager.
IBM Edge Application Manager gives
an administrator the ability to
manage thousands of edge endpoints by
carrying out identification, agreement,
execution, and verification of
management actions without intervention,
driving downadministration costs and streamlining
the deployment of device-specific updates.
In this case, IBM Edge Application Manager helps
to deliver the service right to the cameras,
improving response time by spreading theworkload
across hundreds of these small container-capable
devices -- thereby avoiding the transport/compute
burden of a centralized data center architecture.
It's the first week of the rollout
and the lead technician texts you
that they'vejust installed new machines
at the factory in Tucson, Arizona. Yippee!
You're responsible for verifying that the
equipment has been successfully connected to the
management hub and that the right software gets
installed on the edge devices.
Fortunately, you don’t have to write scripts
with IBM Edge Application Manager. Instead,
you can specify the criteriathat determines
what's deployed to each device -- you don't have
to deal with each individual end point.
The workload, defined as one or more services,
can be automatically deployed because it meets
the criteria you've already set.
Each service represents a set of specific
functionality and includes policies that
assure that the right software is placed
on the right node at the right time.
And the system will automatically update itself
when new workloads or edge nodes are introduced,
or environmental conditions change that
invalidate the original placement decisions.
As we've seen through this brief example, IBM
Edge Application Manager - with its autonomous
management capabilitydelivers
no touch lifecycle management.
When combined with an edge-native
programming model, a single administrator
can securely deliver software to almost
any smart device or cluster capable
of running containerized workloads.
Thanks for watching. If you have any
questions, please add a comment below.
If you want to see more videos like this
in the future, please like and subscribe.